Can we take the biblical,
Andrew Wells asks,
can we take the biblical story seriously
enough with those without also keeping
biblical traditions?
What's the psychological impact
of group gathering church going?
I think we could take the
biblical stories seriously enough,
but I don't think that
it's particularly easy.
Um,
the traditions bind
the community together.
Now I'm saying that and
I don't go to church,
you know,
and the reason I don't go to church
is because while it drives me crazy to
speak,
frankly,
I haven't been able to sit in a
situation like that ever since I was,
whatever.
Really.
That's really the truth of it ever.
Um,
I'm not convinced that that's a good
thing because I do believe and I've had
good conversations about
this with Jonathan Patio,
I do believe that communal return to
the source of the community's ethics is
actually a necessary thing.
And maybe I'm atoning for my past sins
by doing these biblical lectures at the
moment,
which is something that's communal.
So,
and then because there's also something
about going where a bunch of other
people are to reaffirm your commitment to,
to the good that you're all aiming at,
that's got some power in it.
And,
and I don't think that that's
something that we should forgo.
I think it's dangerous.
I mean,
look,
even if you're cynical about church
and I guess I would put myself in that
category,
it's certainly the case that communal
church going in the 19 fifties say,
provided the average person with at
least an hour a week where they were
contemplating no matter how poorly
the purpose of ethics in life and,
and the idea of a higher purpose
and higher meaning in life.
And you got to think that spending an
hour a week thinking about that is better
than never doing it at all.
So I don't know how to,
that tradition can be
revivified in a meaningful way,
but I think it's.
I really do think it's a catastrophe that
we've lost it because we don't have a
center,
an ethical center that holds
our community together.
And the consequence of that is
that we're fragmenting quite badly.
So.